Dès qu’il voit quelqu’un,
il s’aplatit et il urine sous lui
donc c’est un chien,
on lui a maravé la tête.
Bonjour à tous,
je m’appelle Emy
et je fais des vidéos sur Youtube
et voici Morgane
alias Little Gypsy.
Et aujourd’hui,
on va vous emmener avec nous
faire une saisie
dans un élevage de chiens
qui ne respecte pas les normes
et on va vous montrer le suivi,
la deuxième vie
que va lui offrir une association.
Là, on s’en va
dans le centre de la France
avec la fondation
30 millions d’amis.
On va faire un sauvetage
d’une trentaine de chiens.
On est sur un truc assez fort.
Donc, on s’attend à voir des bêtes
qui sont peut-être mal nourries,
peut-être très sales,
peut-être avec des maladies,
dans des espaces très restreints.
Donc, on y va un peu
avec de l’appréhension…
Bonjour, Bonjour.
- Bonjour,
donc, voilà mes collègues.
On rentre.
Il y a un état des lieux
qui est en train de se faire,
le nombre de chiens,
comment les transporter…
On attend le camion
avec toutes les cages à l’intérieur
pour pouvoir
embarquer les chiens
et les apporter au refuge
30 millions d’amis dans la foulée.
Pour le coup, elle a tout nettoyé.
Donc, ce qu’on voit ce n’est pas
choquant entre guillemets
mais il faut imaginer
qu’il y a quelques jours
c’était bien pire que ça.
Ici, il y avait des cockers,
ils vivaient dans leurs excréments
et là, tout est propre.
On n’est pas montés
encore au-dessus
et au-dessus, apparemment
c'est là où c’est le pire
et c’est là où les chiens
vivent que sur du béton.
Ils sont hyper agités,
ils n’en peuvent plus.
Les box sont petits,
c’est que des mâles,
ça va être chaud.
Il est tout maigre !
T'as vu ?
Normalement,
dans les gamelles d’eau
au niveau de l’hygiène,
tous les matins
on est censé nettoyer
avec une éponge
et quand tu regardes l’intérieur,
ce n’est pas du tout nettoyé
depuis au moins plusieurs semaines,
il y a de la vase
et ça, niveau hygiène,
ce n'est pas du tout aux normes.
Les chiens dorment sur du béton.
Ils n'ont rien pour
s’allonger quelque part.
Ils ne sont pas isolés
du froid parce que là,
on est au centre
de la France donc l’hiver,
il fait très froid et là,
il n’y a rien du tout pour eux,
pour qu’ils puissent
être isolés.
La fondation pense
qu’ils ont la giardiose.
C’est des vers
et c’est hyper contagieux
pour tous les autres animaux
qui sont dans le refuge.
Et normalement, quand
un animal chope cette maladie,
il doit être dans
une pharmacie à l’extérieur
pour pas que les autres
attrapent cette maladie
et tu peux remarquer
qu’il y a beaucoup de ces chiens
qui sont assez maigres
et qui ont le poil vraiment terne
et à mon avis, ils ont tous
la giardiose, là, en ce moment.
Elle est trop belle !
Je suis un peu horrifiée
par l’endroit
qui est glauque, sale
et qui pue,
qui pue la mort clairement.
Et puis les cages là-bas,
c’est l’hécatombe.
Les cages là-bas, ils sont
très agités, très nombreux.
Ils n’ont pas accès à l’eau tous,
comme ils devraient avoir,
c’est un minimum.
- Le minimum qu’on devrait donner
aux animaux
déjà, c’est à manger et à boire.
En fait là, pendant
qu’ils les embarquent,
ils en profitent pour recenser
tous les chiens qu’ils récupèrent
donc ils les bipent,
c’est un peu bizarre
de le dire comme ça,
ils les bipent
et ils cochent
comme ça, ils tiennent
une liste pour pouvoir
emmener tous les chiens
et les identifier en même temps.
- Du coup, on va charger ces deux-là.
On a un animal qui s’est blessé
au niveau de l’œil,
il a une cicatrice
donc je pense que
c’est une bagarre entre eux.
On en a un autre
qui est complètement efflanqué.
Donc, soit effectivement,
il ne mange pas.
C'est le paria,
les autres sont plus dominants
donc, ils mangent et après,
le laissent manger ce qui reste.
On a plein de soucis déjà là.
On est à peine au début,
on voit qu’il y a plein de problèmes.
Tu veux en prendre un ?
- Allez.
Je rentre.
- Non, n'aie pas peur bébé !
Vous les sortez
par deux ou par trois ?
- Oh non, on sort
tout le monde en même temps.
- Tout le monde en même temps ?
Et ça s'entend bien ?
- Bah oui.
J’ai des photos.
Oh non, je vous crois,
c’est une question…
Le problème,
c’est que ce sont des animaux
qui ne sont jamais
sortis de leur box
ou si au pire,
ils sont sortis de leur box,
ils ne sont jamais
sortis en laisse
donc ils ne connaissent pas
la contrainte,
ils sont complètement terrorisés.
Ce sont des animaux,
en fin de compte,
qui n’ont jamais été manipulés.
Elle a fait de la reproduction
mais honnêtement, je pense,
sans les vouloir et du coup,
elle a été dépassée.
Après là, on est quand même
avec quelqu’un qui dit aimer les animaux
et qui n’assume pas
du tout son amour
et qui, au contraire,
fait l’inverse de ce qu’elle devrait faire
parce que là, on est vraiment
avec des animaux
qui sont
complètement asociaux.
Il y a un vrai travail derrière
pour le refuge,
pour pouvoir en fin de compte,
réhabituer l'animal par rapport à l'homme.
Il y a un vrai problème
dans l'élevage.
De toute façon, on est bien contents
que ça se termine en procédure.
- Ça, c'est Maestro.
- Donc qui n'aime pas les femmes ?
- Non, non mais bon,
là ça passe avec vous
mais ça dépend,
je préfère le dire.
Alors ça, c’est un chien
qui est censé ne pas aimer les femmes
mais en fin de compte,
qui est terrorisé.
Apparemment, dès qu’il voit quelqu’un,
il s’aplatit et il urine sous lui
donc c’est un chien,
on lui a maravé la tête.
C’est hyper anxiogène en fait.
Vous pouvez commencer
à prendre les chiots si vous voulez.
Il y avait la femelle.
- La mère, je la sentais
un peu protectrice.
- Je vais la sortir alors.
Tout va bien, c’est moi.
Bah oui.
C’est l’enfer là.
Vous n’avez pas
le même âge tous les deux,
vous ne faites pas
le même poids !
Eux au moins,
ils n’auront pas eu
la vie dure pendant longtemps.
Je peux les garder
dans mes bras,
il n’y a pas de souci.
Franchement, émotionnellement,
c’est hyper…
Les chiots en plus,
tu les as contre toi.
En fait, ils cherchent le contact,
je pense qu’ils n’ont pas
trop l’habitude
et le petit s’endormait
vraiment dans mon cou.
C’est hyper difficile
de les laisser en fait.
Même si c’est pour le mieux,
tu sais que
c’est pour le mieux en plus,
c’est juste sur le moment,
c’est violent quoi.
Ça va ?
- Ouais, c’est un peu violent,
je m’y attendais un peu,
je m’y attendais mais tu ne peux pas
contrôler sur le moment.
Salut les pépères !
Oulalala !
Ça, c’est une preuve aussi
qu’elle n’entretient pas du tout ses chiens
et qu’ils sont dans
des conditions pas du tout…
- Regarde les yeux !
Il y a du pus qui sort.
Putain, t’as l’impression
qu’ils découvrent l’herbe quoi.
Oh, les oreilles !
Bonjour les oreilles !
- Viens mon amour.
On vient d’arriver à Provins,
dans le refuge
de 30 millions d’amis.
On va descendre toutes
les cages et voir tous les bébés,
leur montrer
leur nouvelle maison
et ils passeront
du coup demain :
vétérinaire, visite,
toilettage, contrôle, etc.
Là, c’est la première étape,
ils vont être confrontés
à leur nouvel environnement là,
pour la première fois.
Bon , on va porter les cages,
on va tous les rentrer.
- C'est rien !
Tout va bien se passer.
Voilà.
Où est-ce qu’il faut
te les poser les deux-là ?
On va les emmener
directement dans leur box.
C’est moins agressif
dès que tu arrives quoi.
Tout est clean, tout est propre
et ça n’a rien à voir.
On ne se rend pas compte
peut-être à l’image
mais c’était ultra glauque
ce matin.
Moi, je suis un peu marquée.
Maintenant, ce qui va être dur,
c’est de les laisser quoi.
T’entends, c’est trop beau !
Bonjour, je craque.
C’est bon,
on s’est reconverties nous,
on arrête tout et
on reste vivre ici avec eux.
- Franchement moi,
je ne dis pas non
je ne dis pas non.
On vient vous voir
parce qu’on a saisi ces chiots
il y a à peu près deux jours
et voir s’ils avaient
d’autres problèmes.
- Ok, on va commencer.
- Allez.
- Ça va,
ils ont bien mangé depuis ?
Alors, ils ne sont plus
avec leur mère,
parce que la personne qui les avait,
les séparait de la mère.
- D’accord.
- Donc, nous on leur donne
du "Mini Puppy"
avec de l’a/d en complément
et on voulait savoir justement
si c’était suffisant ou pas
ou s’il fallait changer l’alimentation,
mais ils mangent.
- A priori s’ils mangent,
je pense que s’ils sont sevrés
vu la taille qu’ils font, ils doivent
avoir un peu plus de 4/5 semaines.
- D'accord.
T’aimes pas le bidou ?
Quand il y a
des sauvetages comme ça,
c’est quoi les premières choses
que vous regardez
au niveau de leur santé ?
C’est le parasitisme
en général qui va poser problème.
Bon, malnutrition...
Dans les élevages en général,
ils essaient de leur donner
à manger quand même.
Ouais.
C’est souvent le parasitisme,
aussi bien les puces
que les parasites internes.
Donc là, ils sont assez âgés
pour être identifiés.
- C’est bien qu’un animal
soit identifié.
Comme ça, on est sûr que ce
qu’on fait c’est bien à lui
et pas à un autre
qui lui ressemble
et ensuite la loi dit
que pour donner ou vendre
un animal,
il doit être identifié.
C’est une obligation légale.
On va vérifier avant
de mettre une puce
qu’il n’y en a pas déjà une.
- D’accord.
- C'est un mauvais moment à passer.
Bravo, bravo.
Tu pourras charrier ton frère,
t'as fait moins de bruit.
Merci beaucoup en tout cas.
- Merci !
Au tout début,
quand on a vu les chiens
on a dit qu’on aimerait trop,
secrètement leur donner
un prénom chacuneplayProperty":"Text"}
et là, on a le droit.
Du coup, voici Blue,
la femelle
et Orca.
T’aimes bien ton prénom ?
Ou tu m’en veux déjà ?
C’est un problème
de parents ça.
Ohlala, bébé.
- Bah oui, il a des abcès,
sur la tête aussi.
Là, on lui a fait des injections
d’anti-inflammatoires
et d’antidouleurs,
aussi bien pour
les abcès que la patte.
Par contre, si demain
ça ne s’est pas amélioré,
il va chez le véto.
- Ok.
Parce que comme demain
on emmène des chiens
qui sont en consultation.
Il n’a l’air vraiment pas bien.
Il me fait trop de peine.
Alors le souci, c’est que ces
petits bonhommes là,
on ne peut pas
leur mettre des couvertures
parce qu’ils les déchiquètent
et ils les avalent.
- C'est pour ça qu'ils ont
les petites lumières chauffantes ?
- Oui.
Ouais,
tu t’es bien fait castagner.
- Et puis sa patte,
mais par sécurité, il vaut mieux
l’emmener chez le vétérinaire
faire une radio, pour être sûr
qu’il n’y a pas de fracture ou autre chose.
- Ça va la belle ?
- C'est plus propre ici, hein ?
C’est mieux ?
Elle est très abîmée elle,
quand même.
Elle est très maigre.
Je pense que
ça devait être une reproductrice et
elle l'a usée, elle est allée
jusqu’au bout quoi.
Les élevages
qui s'en occupent mal,
ils veulent juste
qu'elles fassent des bébés,
qu’elles fassent des bébés,
Ils ne suivent pas les normes
de reproduction et d'espace
entre chaque portée
et ça donne vraiment des chiens
très usés et dans cet état-là.
Le bien-être animal,
il n’existe pas,
il est zéro là.
Il faut produire, produire,
produire...
- Pour faire de l'argent.
Il n’y en a pas un
qui est agressif ?
- Aucun. Zéro.
Sur tous ceux qu’elle nous avait
dit où il y avait un risque,
zéro.
Ils sont tous en manque d'amour,
ils ne demandent que ça.
Venez tous dans les refuges,
venez tous les adopter
parce qu’ils méritent tellement
d'avoir de l'amour et de sortir d'ici.
Ce n'est pas eux qui devraient
être derrière les barreaux.
Non, c’est clair.
C’est pas eux les coupables.
Là du coup,
vous avez tout un travail à faire
de lui apprendre aussi
à aimer un jouet.
- À apprendre à avoir confiance
en l'être humain.
- À être un chien.
La vie que tous
les chiens devraient avoir.
C'est sûr que ce n'est pas un chien
qu'on va acheter
dans une animalerie
ou un élevage.
Là, c’est un chien qu'on adopte
avec un lourd passé
mais qui a déjà un peu effacé
ce qui lui est arrivé auparavant
mais il faut beaucoup
de patience surtout.
On ne peut pas se permettre
de prendre un animal
et se dire :
"Au bout de 15 jours,
finalement je n’en veux plus,
j’en veux un autre."
- C’est une responsabilité en fait,
financière, affective.
Il y a des gens peut-être qui n'ont
jamais eu d'animaux dans leur vie
donc, ils se disent :
"Un chien, c'est un chien".
Ils ne savent pas qu’ils peuvent
avoir un lien fort ,
et créer quelque chose d'unique.